[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
Madeleine Grant assistant comment editor
at the Daily Telegraph and Anna subri
Barrister and former government Minister
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well the eye looks at the worsening
winter crisis engulfing the NHS and says
it's come after years of warnings from
doctors paramedics and financial experts
the guardian speaks to the leader of the
nurses Union the RCN who accuses Health
secretary Steve Barkley of what she
calls bully boy tactics unwilling to
negotiate with a woman who represents a
largely female Workforce
the telegraph says the strikes by nurses
next week will mean the cancellation of
15
000 Hospital operations
the financial times leads with a warning
from the chancellor to trade unions that
the wave of pay strikes this winter is
threatening the country's economic
recovery and that high wage demands only
hurt the workers they're trying to
protect
the times focuses on the rail strikes
with a warning to passengers that
services will be disrupted every day for
a month at least until January the 8th
according to the mail the strikes will
hold Britain hostage and it carries a
warning of people not to fall ill rely
on trains or even send Christmas cards
the express claims an exclusive with
comments from the newest country to join
the Commonwealth Gabon which says that
Harry and Megan are tarnishing the late
Queen's Legacy with their Netflix series
which criticizes many aspects of the
royal household
game of two halves The star looks ahead
to the England France World Cup
quarterfinal and Qatar predicting that
30 million people in the UK will tune in
to watch
while the mirror sums up England's
chances against France this way yes we
can
and finally the sun urges the England
team on with this headline now let's
make French toast lads
hope you get that and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by Madeleine Grant
assistant comment editor at the Daily
Telegraph and Anna subri Barrister and
former government Minister welcome to
you both let us start with the ft and
their front page hunt tells unions pay
demands risk locking in a higher
inflation uh displaying his view that
there are consequences for high pay
Rises Madeleine take us into this
yes absolutely
um well I mean all sorts of incredibly
chaotic front pages that um for foretell
of a very chaotic winter ahead
um and Jeremy Hunt has issued a warning
to Trade union leaders that they risk
jeopardizing the economic recovery uh
with their High pay demands um saying
that that will impact the fights against
inflation and It ultimately harm the
workers that they're trying to protect I
mean I'm not really sure that this line
is going to wash um I mean it's a tricky
one to hold right now because due to the
labor of shortages across the workforce
um companies in the private sector are
increasingly offering higher wages in
order to retain stuff so a certain
amount of weight spiraling is inevitable
and it's harder to argue against in the
public sector but at the same time I
think what they are trying to do also is
to really run home the point that these
strikes were themselves caused by
Soaring inflation and that once prices
get out of control you know almost
everything else starts to go haywire and
then more straight up strike action more
disruption becomes inevitable and the
more it spirals the worse it will be
um so you know it's a very very tricky
type rope that they're attempting to
walk at the moment and Anna has quoted
as saying if we make the wrong choices
now we won't have that 3.7 of inflation
in January or February of 2024 and this
will change from being a one-off problem
to being a permanent problem he's
talking about that uh 3.7 percent
um that the office for Budget
responsibility is predicted
yes and let's hope that their prediction
is right but I mean the government is in
a very difficult position because you
know they that there's a there's a limit
as to what government can do to try and
get a grip on inflation we all know the
consequences of inflation with soaring
prices and the cost of living crisis and
so on and so forth and so there is a
very strong argument that government is
constrained and can only when it comes
to public sector workers only pay the in
accordance with the recommendations from
the various independent pay reviews and
can't give those sorts of increases
which obviously many people want and I
think large sectors of the public
certainly when it comes to nurses
actually supports because as I say
governments Limited in what it can do to
bring inflation under control and one of
those things is making sure that those
people effectively it pays don't have
increases over the rate of inflation
we moved to the Telegraph and they are
highlighting some of the consequences of
the the strikes um they have figures
suggesting that up to 15 000 operations
will be canceled next week because of
the first national strike by by nurses
Madeleine
yes that's right and um you know some of
these I suppose will be so-called
non-essential operations
um hip and knee Replacements cataracts
and that sort of thing
um but another important statistic in in
the article there is that the fact that
of the 7.6 million people who are now on
an NHS waiting list 400 000 of them have
been waiting for more than a year which
is absolutely devastating and actually
feeds into uh what we were talking about
earlier with Jeremy Hunt and the
inflation there that uh there are so
many people who cannot re-enter the
workforce because they are waiting on an
operation so that there's kind of chaos
that creates further chaos
um in other parts of the economy
um and another big worry is that with
all of these even if these some of these
operations are thought to be less
essential that there will just be such
enormous pressure on a e departments
um as people can't access their usual
care that it will have all sorts of uh
repercussions on the most basic
Healthcare
um so it will be you know a very very
worrying time and it's not a surprise to
see it consuming so much
um so many of the headlines tonight
yes the telegraph are also disclosing
concerns from senior military figures
unhappy that soldiers could be made to
give up their their Christmas to to
cover
yes and and I think that this is all
part of a wider narrative that actually
is quite interesting because I think
this isn't just about people wanting
wage Rises over above the rate of
inflation because they're feeling
discreet I think generally in the
country there's a feeling that people
are pretty pickled off actually and
people are fed up and they're fed up
with this government and whether this
government likes it or not in any event
when it comes to strikes they will blame
government for not fixing them for not
getting I don't Lynch the rmt whatever
but in relation to the NHS in particular
I think people have just had enough of
this appalling crisis that the NHS is in
and they know that the responsibility
for solving that crisis lies with the
government and I may be wrong and I know
you'll correct me if I am I don't think
we've even had the details yet of the
government's winter plan have we we
certainly haven't had details of their
Workforce plan and this is absolutely
shameful because of the appalling State
the nhss is in and I don't think people
will turn their ire on whether it's
paramedics ambulance workers and nurses
when they go on strike I think they will
absolutely blame this government rightly
so for the way it's let down the NHS
over a number of years now but we hear
from members of the government
conservative MPS their message to the
public don't fall ill don't rely on
trains and forget sending Christmas
cards uh the headline there that um
really the country is being held to
hostage I mean do you agree with that
Madeleine
well it's just it all feeds into this
this feeling that is so common right now
that you know nothing really seems to
work that everything is a bit broken and
ossified and living normal life is is
very very difficult and I think Anna's
quite right that people will For Better
or Worse always blame the government for
that
um ditto inflation even though it may be
a global phenomenon it's the kind of
thing that tends to topple whoever is in
charge when it gets out of hand
um and there's so little wiggle room
um for what the government can do both
in terms of how they can get this under
control given the very limited space
they have for maneuver but also I think
in trying to regain the narrative in any
way shape or form I mean it does seem
like the strikes is about one of the
very few issues that they're actually
able to take the fight to the labor
party a bit because there are just so
many issues that it's you know they gain
Nothing by mentioning them they can't
talk about the NHS because it's a
complete disaster
um but with with the strikes it's
perhaps one area where it does make the
label a party a bit uneasy about but on
the whole it seems that
um
so many things across the board are no
longer functioning but also the
government's ability to counteract that
narrative with either words or action is
is also incredibly weak
Christmas is going to be miserable at
best and dangerous at worst do you agree
Anna
well I mean it's not great is it I mean
it's I mean but I think the male you
know using these these expressions like
whole you know we're being held to
hostage and all the rest of it I don't
think that resonates with the British
public but I think reasons that
Madeleine and I both agree about
actually I think there's this sense that
things aren't working and everybody's
just fed up now it's cold
um it's pretty grim and miserable and
people are fed up and they're right to
be fed up because there's been a
miserable failure by this government
over a number of years of gross
incompetence and a complete lack of
trust and people have just had enough
Anna madlyn thank you so much for the
moment we are going to take a break and
tomorrow's sun looks ahead to tomorrow's
football with the headline now let's
make French toast lads
can we talk about that animal when we
come back
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Madeleine Grant
assistant comment editor at the Daily
Telegraph and Anna subri Barrister and a
former government Minister it is a game
of two halves Anna but will we be
celebrating at the end of them
foreign
look I'm of that age where I have spent
so many
hours watching England play full of Hope
full of anticipation desperate for them
to win and then of course all my dreams
being shattered but who knows because it
is the most extraordinary words club by
me setting aside the uh appalling human
rights of the Qatar government putting
that to one side as a game of as games
of football as a tournament it's just
been brilliant and and the two games
that um some people were watching
tonight I obviously was concentrating on
getting ready for my appearance on Sky
News
um but I mean those two games to see
Brazil go out I know penalty shootout
extraordinary and then to see
Netherlands getting that second goal
another then going to the extra time and
then another penalty shootout but
Argentina finally came through so I
don't think I could cope like most
people with a penalty shootout but we're
all set up there you are the mirror yes
we can because of course England's
playing France tomorrow goodness knows
by the way what people in Scotland and
whales think about all of this but they
do reckon that in England there is going
to be a very high turnout of people
watching it on the Telly probably
because at the moment we're all a bit
hard up so we're all staying in huddling
around one bar on on the electric
because yeah they can really afford the
energy but in all seriousness it could
be a cracking game or it could yet be
another night a profound disappointment
no no let's be positive let's be
positive a TV audience of 26.9 million
are expected to watch and uh according
to the sun we're hoping to make French
toast of the opposition Madeleine
mistake
well it's quite hard to say um which of
these which of these front covers is
winning the battle of the the puns and
um I'm quite I quite like the Simplicity
of yes we can
um I mean it's extraordinary the World
Cup fever I mean I'm the first to say
I'm I'm one of these fair weather
football viewers and I'll kind of you
know dip my toe in when things get
exciting and if there's something big
happening but there's something about
the world cup magic that even you know
my uncle who's a season ticket at Aston
Villa would not forgive me for saying
this but people who can sort of take or
leave Football under normal
circumstances we had it on in The
Newsroom at work today Croatia V Brazil
and I suddenly I watched it for about
five minutes and all of a sudden I was
thinking my entire future happiness and
well-being depends on Croatia beating
Brazil and knocking them out of the
World Cup
um there's just something about
um Asana says there's been some
extraordinary matches and I know what
I'm going to be doing on Saturday I'm I
I think it will be if it's too tight I
mean not least because even people who
don't care all that much about football
a lot of Brits care very much about out
to beating the French
um I think that it will be I'm not sure
I could cope emotionally physically
mentally if it becomes too tight I just
I have to leave the room or something
yeah I'm getting quite anxious now just
talking about it but I agree
wholeheartedly with Anna
um not penalties that's that is the
worst no not paradoxes please no no
please please no Anna and Madeline for
the moment thank you